oh hello good morning have you never
been invited to a run share a breakfast
it's like a game Butch Cassidy except
not butch
oh man you old [ __ ] town didn't see you
though but you can't say [ __ ] hound on
basic cable you guys do this at home oh
no we don't get along this well at home
[Music]
but if we use this as a fence we can
make individuals fall martyr come on
it's for mono and ylim oh Sh aren't we
gay enough
[Music]
there are Ausmus this is your grandson
you have a grandson
unbelievable then look no where's the
father
well according to the note he's in jail
so he's moving in thank God for that
coyote problem solved I'm with Child
Protective Services
I'm just gonna look around what they do
is take recognize title then give it a
bit of a cheating twist
bareback mountain that's unusual in the
source material is also gay you have
like two dads sort of I'm gonna be out
of here before New Year's
the boys settled in there in the side
effect
stay listen to me you know going
anywhere
he won't let it happen you have the
biggest heart of any man life
[Music]
you